[Music]
what will the EU due to fuel Europe's
green transition how much funding or the
erasmus+
student exchange program receive to what
extent will Europe's poorer regions
benefit from financial support these are
all vital questions debated in the
European Parliament ahead of a crucial
summit on the --use long-term budget for
the next seven years
also known as the multi-annual financial
framework or mff el cuatro chlorine ala
financière EO no no pensee amo see you
till a edit our tally enos reprogram me
and Abram o Bassanio de Pury George
Perez will appear política que consent
an OD occur Cheerilee distance MEP is
insisted on ambitious funding to be able
to combat climate change they also
warned that turning the Green Deal into
reality with a reduced budget would risk
cutting funding to other successful EU
programs the programme me del Grendel
kayano visionary resource a adeg wat no
ABI amo sostenuto s Austin amo questa
grandes vida de Luna on a rope a segrin
day attention on K depart a totally at
or internationally
sukhumi la ropa Shakira dis Villa peril
appropriate leadership nella Lata I can
be Amenti climatic Parliament wants to
fund digital transformation and continue
to support poorer regions farmers young
people researchers and small businesses
it is also calling for a revamp of how
the EU budget is financed peril
parliamentary up AO a una priority' K
parallel a mental mff a vision a
discussion a solar resource appropriate
de Luna narrow pea
siamo noe adere basta I transfer meant
die belong see nationally a loonie on a
rope a volley ama a very short say in
grado de financial initiative a program
me de Lune european parliament has the
final say over the proposed long-term
budget and mep s have warned they will
only give their consent to a budge
that meets the European Union's
ambitions and needs
[Music]